what's up guys bang bang these five to
six minute updates every saturday get
you up to speed on exactly what happened
to the bitcoin market and boy was this a
wild one don't forget these updates are
brought to you by ftx click on the link
in the description and go trade with
super low fees all right let's get into
this week's update to get started we can
see that bitcoin's trading just above
twenty thousand dollars about twenty
thousand five hundred dollars we can see
that the market cap has drawn all the
way down and is now below 400 billion
dollars now remember bitcoin's inflation
rate still sitting about 1.7
and more than 90 percent of the supply
has been issued we also can see that the
real exchange volume over the last 24
hours is 4.56 billion dollars and miners
have been paid 18.7 million over the
last 24 hours to continue to secure the
most secure computing network in the
world gbtc premium has widened all the
way to 35
and of course we have seen that bitcoin
is down 70 from its last all-time high
if we then go and we compare bitcoin
gold and the s p 500 we see that bitcoin
over a one year period it's down 43
the s p 500 down 13 and gold is up 4
but if you look over any other time
period 2 to 10 years bitcoin continues
to dominate gold and the s p 500
next up we can look at the price closing
history by each individual level bitcoin
has spent only 539 days ever in its life
above the current 20 500 price point
that's about 10.9 percent and so if you
had bought bitcoin 89 of the time and
held until today you would be in profit
if we then go and compare bitcoin gold s
p 500 nasdaq and tlt we see that bitcoin
continues to compound annual growth over
the last decade at 123
and the five year sharp ratio is
absolutely dominant compared to the
other assets next we can switch over we
can take a look at the block ware
intelligence update this is will
clemente the team over at block where
they do a fantastic job first we can go
ahead and take a look that bitcoin
continues to experience one of its
furthest deviations below a 200-day
trend in history it's also the third
lowest in the last 10 years bitcoin also
happens to sit below its four-year trend
for just the third time ever according
to block ware these previous occurrences
took place at the bottom of the 2015
bear market and during the march 2020
liquidity crisis that was related to
cobit 19. of course bitcoin sits below
its 200 weekly moving average for the
only the second time ever with the
previous occurrence during that march
2020 liquidity crisis and then in a
really interesting chart that we haven't
talked about in a long time you can see
that bitcoin's price since it's the
lower bound of its production costs for
the first time since the march 2020
liquidity crisis the idea here is that
bitcoin should at a minimum be worth the
cost of energy to produce it it's a
fantastic insight coming from will the
team over there now bitcoin's market
price finally sits below its realized
price as you can see here with the mv rv
z score sitting right there in that
green area then of course the reserve
risk which was created by hans from
ikeyguy you can see that that also is
one of the lowest readings in history
then if we switch and take a look at the
derivatives the block road team all over
it there's a large decline about three
month futures basis across the board and
then of course if we switch and we take
a look there's over 10 billion futures
open interest in usd has reached its
lowest since december 2020. and then
we've started to see some negative
funding rates across the board at all
venues but would like to carve out a
much longer regime according to will the
team
lastly the options implied volatility
that has driven dramatically upwards as
active managers and market makers seek
to hedge their positions that now is
just shy of the levels reached in mid
may 2021
now remember just because all these
metrics are flashing saying that bitcoin
is much much cheaper than it's
historically been doesn't exactly mean
that this is the bottom nobody has a
crystal ball we are operating within a
very bearish macro environment the
federal reserve continues to hike
interest rates and conduct quantitative
tightening and that means the bitcoin
finally getting the test how will it
perform in a macro bear market since
inception it pretty much has been in the
longest bull market in history and so
naturally people wonder will the macro
win out or will bitcoin the strong
fundamental hash rate hitting all-time
highs and many other metrics going to
continue to accelerate what will end up
winning nobody knows but it's always
important to understand what the
underlying fundamentals and the metrics
of bitcoin are telling us now this
weekly update is brought to you by ftx
go into the description click on the
link you'll be able to buy bitcoin
cryptocurrencies there ftx usually has
very very low fees compared to their
competitors sometimes as much as 85
percent lower they also introducing
digital stocks that will allow you to
buy and sell stocks in the same exact
platform there'll be no trading fees and
no payment for order flow go check out
ftx us click on the link and i will see
all of you next saturday hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time